णमो अरिहंताणं णमो
सिद्धाणं णमो आयरियाणं
णमो उवज्झायाणं णमो लोए
सव्व साहूणं नमः समयसाराय
स्वानुभूत्या चकासते । चित्स्वभावाय भावाय
सर्वभावान्तरच्छिदे परित्यज्य। मंगलं भगवान वीरो,
मंगलं गौतमो गणी। मंगलं कुन्दकुन्दार्यो,
जैनधर्मोऽस्तु मंगलम्॥ सर्व मंगल मांगल्ये
सर्व कल्याण कारिके। प्रधानं सर्व धर्मानु।
दैवं प्रेत ॐकारबिन्दुसंयुक्तं
नित्यं ध्यायन्ति योगिनः।
कामदं मोक्षदं चैव ॐकाराय
नमो नमः राजचन्द्र वचना
में। पत्र number है 103। उम्मई से ये पत्र लिखा
गया है। तो
इसलिए पत्र झूठा।
Mostly ये पत्र
जूठा भाई को लिखा गया
होगा। अनुमान है सारा। अभी सोभाग भाई का contact उनको नहीं हुआ था।
सबसे पहले contact
उनको जूठा भाई से हुआ इस प्रकार से। कहते हैं, उस time में वो आत्मज्ञानी नहीं थे।
भूतकाल में साधना की थी लेकिन
वो तो गिर गए। जातिस्मरण ज्ञान था, वैराग्य था। ज्ञान था,
वैराग्य था, संसार में रुचि नहीं थी, ये सब।
लेकिन आत्मज्ञान नहीं था। अवलोकन
का प्रयोग भी जैसा चाहिए वैसा
नहीं था। लेकिन वैराग्य था इसीलिए,
वैराग्य की अवस्था में, अंदर से
सब कार्य बोझारूप लगता है, संसार बोझारूप लगता है। और इनका तो शादी हो
गया था, 23 साल। शादी हो गया था। तेईस साल की उम्र में। और कमाने के लिए Mumbai जाना
था। Mumbai में रहना था।
परिवार से दूर। अपने परिवार तो
अवानिया गाँव में
रहता था। माँ-बाप वहीं। और कमाने के
लिए
मैंने अकेले का कमाना होता तो दो रोटी चाहिए
किधर भी काम
करना। लेकिन परिवार की
जिम्मेदारी थी। यही।
ये हिंदुस्तान के परिवारों
में इस प्रकार का है
देखिए एक कमावे वो घर के पूरे।
स्त्री बच्चे आदि। है ना? हाँ बाप
पानी। पूरा बोझ एक के ऊपर आता था। Foreign में शायद ये
system नहीं है foreign में सबको
काम करना है। अब यहाँ पर ये है।
कि घर का कमाने वाला जो।
व्यक्ति होता है वो पुरुष होता है। बाकी सब। बाकी सब जो रहते हैं वो
एक ही कमाई के ऊपर निर्भर करते हैं। तो बोझा बढ़ जाता
है। अकेले आदमी को बोझा बढ़
जाता है। इस संबंध में यहाँ
पर बातें हैं। कुटुंब रूपी काजल
की कोठरी में रहने से
संसार बढ़ता है। काजल काला होता है, आँख में डालते हैं।
तो ऐसे घर में रहो। तो ऐसे घर में रहो जहाँ काजल का ही घर हो। और फिर आप दाग
आपको लगे नहीं कालापना, ऐसा कैसे
हो सकता है? आप काजल की कोठरी में रहोगे
तो कालापने का दाग कपड़े को
या आपके अंग को लगे बिना रहेगा नहीं। कितना भी संभल रहो।
दिन भर में, कितना भी संभल के रहो तो भी दाग तो लगने ही वाला है। ये
बात ज्ञान की है कि कुटुंब रूपी काजल की कोठरी में रहने से संसार... जल की कोठरी
में रहने से संसार बढ़ता है। हम पूर्व कर्मों के उदय से एक परिवार
में हम लोग इकट्ठे हुए।
जिसको पहले तो हम जान माँ-बाप को भी नहीं जानते थे पहले। लेकिन जन्म होने
के बाद उनके घर में जन्म हुआ
तो वो हो गए माँ-बाप। धीरे-धीरे बड़े हुए तो पहचानना शुरू हुआ भाई, बहन,
दादी, चाचा, चाची, सब। सबसे
पहले शरीर... सबसे पहले शरीर इसके बाद परिवार से नाता जुड़ता है।
और फिर relation तो है ही society है एक जाति है कुल है।
ज्ञाति है। इस प्रकार से society होता है
फिर। Area wise भी
मंडल बनते हैं वो हर जगह मंडल ही बनते हैं। ये बरकतपुरा colony का
मंडल है सब member बन जाओ भाई। सफाई
अच्छा करो। सफाई अच्छा करने का। फिर building में एक bundle बनता
है। Residential complex का जो होता है ना,
Bhaskar Tower complex residential association, ऐसे association बनते रहते
हैं। एक बरकपुर colony का, फिर
Hyderabad city का, ऐसा बनते रहते हैं। ये social context से जुड़ता है।
वो सबको तो avoid कर सकते हैं लेकिन
परिवार को avoid नहीं कर सकते। सबसे भाग सकते हैं लेकिन परिवार को
एक दिन भी छोड़ना... सकते हैं लेकिन परिवार को
एक दिन भी छोड़ना बहुत मुश्किल है। गए हैं
घूमने के लिए, रोज़ के 4 phone आते हैं, तबीयत कैसी
है, खाना खाए कि नहीं
खाए, yoga करते कि नहीं करते। अब फिर मेरे को ना यही checking होता है।
4 phone मेरे को आते
हैं, 4 phone दूसरों को भी आते
हैं। कहीं मैं झूठ तो नहीं बोल रहा
हूँ। ये क्या है? ये कुटुंब रूपी काजल की कोठरी है।
कुटुंब हमको कुछ नहीं कर सकता है, लेकिन हम attachment में जुड़े
हुए हैं। परिवार हमको कुछ
हैरान नहीं करता है, परिवार हमको राग द्वेष नहीं कराता है। लेकिन
हमारा मोह परिवार के प्रति है। वो हमको राग
द्वेष कराता है। एक तो शरीर के प्रति मोह रहता है।
वो राग द्वेष कराता है सारा दिन। दूसरा next
शरीर है तो परिवार। उनसे जुड़े रहते हैं।
और संसार बढ़ता है माने क्या, संसार माने क्या? कुटुंब परिवार ये संसार नहीं
है। अंदर में राग द्वेष होना वो संसार
है। भूतकाल में राग द्वेष किए थे,
उसके फल में अब ये परिवार आदि मिले हैं, society मिली है, शरीर मिला
है। अब जो राग द्वेष करते हैं, उसका भविष्य में मिलेगा। जैसा बोते हैं,
वैसा पा लेते हैं। जैसी करनी, वैसी भरनी।
बाहर में कोई दुश्मन नहीं है तो हमारे
तो... बाहर में कोई दुश्मन नहीं है तो हमारे तो generally तो हर एक घर के अंदर मित्र
और शत्रु सब घर में ही रहते हैं।
बाहर वाले से तो ऐसा भी लेना देना नहीं।
क्या? अगर वो गाली देवे तो भी अपुन ज्यादा मथापूंड़ी नहीं करते।
कौन जाएगा police में पंचायत अपने भाई? थोड़ा ना मारो ना बकने दो उसको। ऐसा करके
उससे झगड़ा पंचायत नहीं करते लेकिन घर में अगर कोई बोल दिया।
फिर देखो मजा।
जब तक उसको सताएंगे नहीं सामने जवाब देंगे
नहीं। इसका जवाब पत्थर से नहीं देंगे। तब तक जीव को शांति
नहीं होगी। ये अपेक्षा है,
आप अपने हो और अपने हो करके हमारे को इतना करते हो
भला। बात नहीं समझ पाए
तो भी तकलीफ। बात करते करते अगर
समझ नहीं पाए अर्थ, अर्थ का अनर्थ हो गया अगर।
आप मेरी बात ही नहीं समझते। मेरा कहने का ऐसा वैसा नहीं था। कहने का वैसा नहीं
था। मेरा अंतःकरण बिल्कुल शुद्ध है।
लेकिन आप लोग समझ नहीं पाते हो, कभी नहीं समझेंगे मेरे को। ये क्या होता है?
ये घर इतना झगड़ा बाहर वाले अगर नहीं नहीं समझे तो क्या है?
अगर अपनी बात को बाहर वाले नहीं समझे तो क्या है? उसकी मर्जी भैया।
सब अपने-अपने घर के मालिक हैं लेकिन घर में कोई अपनी बात नहीं समझे तो देखो क्या होता
है। नाच लेना कूद लेना पूरा।
और जी भर के राग द्वेष कर लेना।
राग द्वेष कर लेते हैं। एक कुटुंब रूपी काजल की कोठरी से
रहने से संसार बढ़ता है माने राग द्वेष बढ़ता है। वो भी राग द्वेष करे अपने निमित्त से
और उसके निमित्त से हम भी जी भर करके राग द्वेष करें। फिर बाद में तो कहाँ हो
फिर? देह छूट जाएगा बाद में तो
कहाँ मिलना है फिर राग द्वेष करना नहीं है अभी जो है अवसर है
आरम पीटी जितना करना
है। इतनी गालियां देना है जितना प्रेम करना है
अभी कर लो। बाद में कहाँ मिलने वाले हैं बाद में यहाँ से छूट गए ना। बाद में। यहाँ
से छूट गए हम। बाद में कोई
letter या telephone या telephone भी नहीं करने
वाला। मालूम भी नहीं पड़ेगा कहाँ जाएगा। इसीलिए यमराज हमको अलग कर देवे
इसके पहले जी भर करके पूरा हिसाब किताब तय कर ले। बाकी नहीं रखना कुछ भी।
कई घर वालों के साथ हमारा ऐसा है।
कुटुंब रूपी काजल की... नहीं एक एक छोटे छोटे
आप देखना एक एक प्रसंग बनते हैं और एक एक... एक एक प्रसंग बनते हैं और
एक एक छोटी छोटी बात पे कितना discussion होता
है, कितना विवाद खड़ा होता है। एक बोलेगा ऐसा करना,
और कुटुंब परिवार दूसरा बोलेगा नहीं ऐसा नहीं ऐसा
करना। ये serial जो बनती है ना, इसके कारण से बनती है सब। घर में जो
पंचायत होती है। देखना एक एक serial का इसके पीछे heart देखना कितनी पंचायतें हैं
परिवार
में। जो घर की कहानियां जो
होती है वो picture पे लाके। Picture चलाती हूँ। कुटुंब
रूपी काजल की कोठरी। उसमें रहने से
राग लगे बिना रहता नहीं है। राग द्वेष हुए बिना रहते नहीं है
और अशांति हुए बिना नहीं रहती। अशांति का कारण क्या
है? मोह है हमारा। मेरा भाई,
मेरे father, मेरी पत्नी, मेरा पति,
बस मेरा पना लगा दिया है। ऐसे बाजू में पड़ोस में भी जैसे
लोग रहते हैं ऐसे हम नहीं रह सकते हैं अपने घर में।
पड़ोसी के जैसा व्यवहार कैसे करें? फिर अपने में रहूंगा क्या?
क्या फर्क? फिर झगड़ा किससे करना? अगर पड़ोसी रहेंगे पड़ोसी मानेंगे अपने वालों को।
अपने वालों को अगर पड़ोसी मानेंगे
फिर झगड़ा किससे करेंगे? लड़ना झगड़ना किससे होगा? रिस किससे
करेंगे? नहीं बोलना है जाओ
किसको किसको बोलेंगे ऐसा? बातचीत नहीं करेंगे। किसको
बोलेंगे ऐसा बातचीत नहीं करना। क्यों
नहीं करना? क्योंकि मानते नहीं हैं हमारी बात। हमारे उनके विचार नहीं मिलते।
देखिए बाहर वाले के साथ विचार नहीं मिले तो क्या करते हो?
बात नहीं करते हो, जीत नहीं करते हो, क्या नहीं करते हो? ऐसे बहुत से लोग हैं जिनके
अपने साथ बहुत से लोगों को विचार नहीं मिलते, क्या करते हो?
द्वेष करते हो।
ऐसा ये वितराग धर्म है, बहुत से जीव नहीं मानते हैं, हम नहीं मानते
हैं। क्या करते हो? झगड़ा पंचायत।
क्या करते हो झगड़ा पंचर? नहीं मानो भैया तुम मानी मर्जी।
मानना है मानो नहीं मानना है मत मानो।
लेकिन घर में अगर कुछ हवे एक-दुई
छोटी सी बात संसार के level की
बात भी देखो कोई नहीं माने। विचार नहीं मिले तो देखो कैसा होता है समाधान। वो
बिना वजह का tension सर पे रहता है। जब तक वो
अभी थोड़े दिन में वापस मिल जाते हैं क्योंकि कितना दिन दुख में रहो
कि रहना तो इत्थे ही है
कि घर छोड़ के भागना थोड़ा है। घर छोड़ के जाओ फिर TV
नया लेना पड़े, घर अलग लेना पड़े।
एक पंचायत थोड़ी। ये तो ये
अच्छा है कि एक ही TV में सब लोग देख सकते हैं। अलग हो गए तो क्या हुआ?
किराया अलग भरना। सब अलग-अलग, घर का कितना बढ़ जावे उतना तो कमाते नहीं हैं।
कभी-कभी मजबूरी से साथ में रहना पड़ता है। रहना एक पल भी नहीं है लेकिन क्या करें।
हाँ अगर हमारा हिस्सा दे
दे तो हम चले जाएँ अभी। देते तो हम चले जाते अभी। Partition तक।
हम भी इसके हैं। ये property जो होती है ना वो बांध के रखती है।
कोई भागता नहीं है कि नहीं मुझे कुछ नहीं चाहिए मैं चलता हूँ, मुझे शांति चाहिए।
ऐसे बहुत कम मिलेंगे।
क्योंकि जब तक मेरे हिस्से का मुझे नहीं मिलेगा ना
तब तक मैं घर छोड़ने
वाला नहीं हूँ। और आपको चैन से जीने नहीं दूँगा। Picture भी आते हैं बेचैन से
जीने नहीं दूँगा करके। जाते हैं बेचैन से जीने नहीं दूंगा करके ऐसे
picture title भी ऐसे रहते हैं। जीने नहीं दूंगा।
मार डालूंगा ऐसे title रहते हैं। इंतकाम। ये सब क्या क्या है ये सब लफड़े।
हमने देखा नमोद सु के घर बम्बई में।
मैं समझता हूं अभी तो उनकी value बहुत बढ़ गई है बाप दादा की जमीन है।
जहां पर वो रहते हैं पूरी building उनकी है। लेकिन पुराने
rent tax वगैरह सब। क्योंकि पुराने rent act वगैरह सब किराए पे कोई खाली करता नहीं है।
खाली करे तो नाम बदली का जो मिलता है सो
मिलता है बाकी कुछ नहीं मिलता। और repairing करने के पैसे नहीं हैं और ये
एक property जो है संयुक्त परिवार में है। किसी के
विचार नहीं मिलते एक
ही घर के अंदर दो
भाइयों के विचार नहीं साथ में रहते हैं
दीरानी जेठानी जेठानी अलग से जाके खाना बनाएगी अपना।
फिर वो उसका timing निकल जाती है फिर दीरानी जाके
अपना खाना। निकल जाती है फिर दीरानी जाकर अपना खाना
अलग बनाती है। घर में रहते हैं दिन भर बातचीत नहीं करते।
क्या? वो एक दूसरे के
बच्चों को भी लाड़ नहीं करते क्योंकि लाड़ करेंगे तो वो अभिषेक हो जाएगा नहीं दूर रहो।
Alert alert वो alert क्या लाड़ नहीं करना है। लाड़ नहीं करने का alertness।
किसका लफड़ा है मालूम है?
कि बटवारा हो नहीं सकता। इतनी value है किसी एक में भी ताकत।
किसी एक में भी ताक़त नहीं है कि
कुछ ले लें पूरा और उसको अपना हिस्सा दे दें।
इतनी ताक़त नहीं है। अब क्या करना है? ज़िंदगी भर रोते रहना है। ऐसी property
नहीं है तो भी अच्छा है, मैं तो बोलता
हूँ। क्या? कई लोगों की property नहीं होती है। क्या करते हैं?
नहीं जीते हैं, मज़े से जीते हैं।
ये property रख ले करते हैं। कितने दुखी? कि न साथ में रह सकते हैं,
न प्यार से रह सकते हैं और न
अलग भी हो सकते हैं। तो life... एक live example दे रहा
हूँ मैं। क्या करें? जो main था वो गुज़र गया है, दादी माँ है।
जो भी आया हो, कुछ भी हुआ ना दादी माँ पे। मारो जो चाहे दादी माँ पे।
आपके वजह से। बंटवारा करो ना। लेकिन बोले कैसे
करूँ बताइए आप, कौन देता है चलो? चलो ₹1,00,00,000 की property है। चलो तुमको
अलग होना है। चलो हम
अलग करने को तैयार हैं लेकिन
इसमें... चलो हम अलग करने को तैयार हैं लेकिन इसमें
ताकत होनी चाहिए ना कि तेरा हिस्सा दे सके
cash में। ताकत नहीं। ऐसे
यहाँ पर भी अपने मुंसिपल एरिया में बहुत से लोगों का ऐसा ही problem है,
property का बहुत problem है। ना संभाल सकते हैं,
ना उसका rent भर सकते हैं, ना repairing करा सकते हैं, ना रह सकते हैं।
ना किराया भी आता है, वो मौज करता है।
जो अंदर घुस गया है ना किराए पे वो देख लिया है कि झगड़े पे। वो देख लिया है कि
झगड़े पंचायत पड़े हैं आपस के लोगों।
किराया नहीं देंगे जो जाओ वो काम करो। कौन जाएगा court में? मजे
में रहो जब दूंगा साथ में court में दूंगा मैं पैसा। और ये लोग आपस में झगड़ झगड़ के
ना property को निकालते हैं ना बेचते हैं ना किराया वसूल कर सकते हैं।
एक वो गांव में पड़ी है एक इधर पड़ी है एक उधर पड़ी है और धुन खाती है।
नसीब में नहीं है भोगने का।
ऐसे तो बहुत से रोज के किस्से हैं आप कितने बताऊँ अपने
इधर file खोलोगे तो बहुत से
निकल जाएंगे। तो मोह से निकल जाएगा। ऐसे होगा। घर-घर में लड़ाइयां होती हैं। ये
कुटुंब रूपी काजल की कोठरी में रहने से संसार बढ़ता है।
ना छोड़ना होता है, ना साथ में चैन से रहना होता है।
और राग-द्वेष, राग-द्वेष, राग-द्वेष, राग-द्वेष। तीव्र मोह,
कुटुंब से ज्यादा तीव्र मोह है तो राग-द्वेष भी तीव्र है।
शरीर से ज्यादा मोह है तो उसमें
उसके प्रति भी बहुत लगाव है। जरा कुछ हुआ तो ऊपर-नीचे हो जाते हैं। जरा कुछ हुआ तो ऊपर
नीचे हो जाते हैं। चैन करना तो
बस की बात ही नहीं है। चाहे
जितना उसका सुधार करें, बहुत कितना भी अलट-पलट राग-द्वेष नहीं करना है।
जोर से नहीं बोलना है, वो भी परमात्मा है, गुरु ने बोला है कि उसमें ही आत्मा देखो।
उससे प्रेम करो। लेकिन
नहीं बोलना, नहीं बोलना, नहीं
बोलना, उसका बोझा... नहीं बोलना नहीं बोलना उसका बोझा इतना बढ़ जाता
आखिर एक दफे तो पूरा साथ में निकल के बोल देना
होता है। इतने दिन से जमा किया दो चार दिन से नहीं बोलना है नहीं बोलना है नहीं बोलना
है। क्या हुआ? एक थप्पड़ मारे ना इधर तो दूसरा गाल देना इधर।
लेकिन तीसरा मारे तो? की मार देना। इस दो का ही छूट है।
इधर खाना एक किधर खाना अब तीसरा तो है नहीं।
तीसरा मारो फिर देखो तुम्हारे हाथ पैर नहीं तोड़े तो बोलना।
क्या? क्या? ऐसे ही एक दिन नहीं बोलना है, दूसरे दिन नहीं बोलना है, तीसरे
दिन नहीं बोलना है, चार दिन नहीं बोलना है, कुछ बोलना
नहीं है, अवलोकन में रहो भैया, कर्म नहीं मानना है।
फिर वो जो file जमा होती है दमन कर कर। जो file जमा हो
के एक दिन पूरी बरसात बरसती
है। क्या? अंदर में घुट घुट करके।
पूरा एक दिन में पूरा खाली होना होता है, तब ऐसा लगता है एक second भी
साथ में नहीं रहना। लेकिन... कन्नू साथ में नहीं रहना। लेकिन कैसे
भागोगे भैया हिस्सा नहीं मिलेगा जब तक कैसे जाओगे? हिस्सा मिलेगा तो
अभी चले जाओगे। अगर ऐसे
लड़ झगड़ के निकल जाएंगे तो पूरा हिस्सा किसको मिलेगा?
अपने दुश्मन को मिल जाएगा। वो दुश्मन है ना घर वाले दुश्मन।
तो मैं मेरा ही कन्ना काटूंगा? नहीं नहीं उसको तो साथ में लेकर के पूरे पाठ पढ़ाना।
खुद भी पढ़ना, रूचा खुद भी खाना और दूसरों को भी मारना, दूसरों को भी उसको भी खिलाना।
को भी मारना उसको भी खिलाना। रोज पंचायत करना। इसका आदि
हो गया है ये जीव। कुटुंब रूपी
काजल की कोठरी में रहने से संसार बढ़ता है।
चाहे जितना उसका सुधार करे तो भी
एकांतवास से जितना संसार अब क्षय होने वाला
है। द्वेष कम होने वाला
है। जीव को शांति मिलने वाली है। अकेले रहने से। खुद का खुद का जीव
मिल जाता है। खुद का खुद का जिम्मेदार है। वो भी जितना ज़रूरत
है उतना इससे ज़्यादा पंचायत नहीं।
Limited अपने पुरता। 4 साल 4 4 8 दिन
का ज़िंदगी है। क्या
और इतने इल्ज़ाम। पार्टी में कहते थे ज़िंदगी टुँकी छै। और झंझट।
ना मिलै छै। क्या करना? झंझट को टुँकी करो तो ज़िंदगी अपनी बड़ी।
ये 24 घंटे के 25 घंटे होने वाला नहीं है जो भी खेल। के 25 घंटे
होने वाला नहीं है जो भी खेल है वो 24 घंटे का है। अब उसमें
आप कितने percentage आप अपने आत्मा
के लिए दे सकते हो? अगर खुद के ऊपर ही खुद की limited जवाबदारी ले
लेते हो, खुद के जितनी, कि
नहीं सबको पढ़ाना लिखाना भाइयों को भी सेवा करना
माँ बाप की सेवा करना सब लफड़ा ले लो तो क्या होगा?
अनंत भव में ऐसा ही किया है पागल। जो अपने नहीं हैं, जो वास्तव में पराए हैं
उसको अपना... संसार में पराए हैं उसको अपना मान करके सबकी हजामत की है।
और फिर जो बाप के पोटले बांधे, कर्म किए वो कौन भोगा?
अकेले ने भोगा। रामायण को
लिखने वाले जो वाल्मीकि ऋषि हैं, उनकी बात आती है वालिया लुटेरा। वो डाकू था वालिया।
वो जंगल में जाता था।
वो हिरण को मार के, भैंसों को मार करके सब लेके आता था शिकार
को। एक दिन माँ... एक दिन महापुरुष मिले। तो
बोले क्या करते हो देखो ऐसे भोले प्राणियों को मारते हो
तुझे बहुत पाप होगा। मैं अकेला थोड़ा करता हूँ मेरा पूरा परिवार है बूढ़े माँ बाप हैं।
wife है बच्चे हैं सबके लिए करता हूँ सब लोग रिश्तेदार हैं। मैं अकेला कैसे भोगूँगा?
इसको हिरन को मारा है तो सब साथ खाने वाले हैं। सबको भोगना पड़ेगा पाप मैं अकेला कैसे
भोगूँगा? कि नहीं। मैं अकेला कैसे भागूँ? कि नहीं ऐसा नहीं है। तुम्हारी गलतफहमी
है देखो अच्छी तरह से। समझो।
कि नहीं मैं ऐसा नहीं मानता मेरे को proof करके दिखाओ। फिर proof करके दिखाते हैं।
क्या होता है? वो wrong करता है plan पूरा ready था।
घर पे जाकर के 4 दिन तक जाता नहीं सिखाने। घर के लोग भूखे मर रहे
हैं। सब लोग चाहते हैं कि
इसका दर्द मिट जाए और इसका रोना चिनाना बंद हो जाए।
जल्दी से अच्छा हो जाए जल्दी पे जावे
काम पे। से अच्छा होए जल्दी पे जावे काम पे। और खाना लेके
आवे हम लोगों के लिए हम भी भूखे मर रहे हैं।
और फिर क्या होता है? तो
उसके चिल्लाना बंद नहीं होता है जितने महापुरुष आते हैं वहां से।
घरवाले परेशान हो करके महाराज आप भी कुछ कृपा करो कुछ vibration दो आपके पास। इसको
कुछ। आप ही बचा सकते हो कोई शरण नहीं है।
आपकी जो तपस्या की है ना
उसका थोड़ा percentage हमारे को दो। उसका थोड़ा
percentage हमारे को दो अच्छा। आपके vibration चाहिए हमारे को क्या है पधारो।
फिर वो
जबरदस्ती करके लेके आते हैं। संसार के हेतु संत का
संत की भक्ति करते हैं संसार बढ़ाने के
लिए। तो पूरा plan था वो तो आए अच्छा क्या हुआ
है। वो ध्यान में बैठते हैं ओ समझ में आ गया
क्या है। इसके प्राण तो अभी 1 घंटा भी नहीं टिकेगा ये। क्या
बात है। क्या बात करते हो फिर हम कहाँ जाएँगे?
सबको चिंता है। माँ-बाप रोने लगे, wife रोने लगे,
बच्चे रोने लगे।
नहीं महाराज साहब कुछ करो आप vibration
कुछ दो आप। कुछ मंत्र-दंतर दो, कुछ तावीज़ बांधेंगे, कुछ भी करेंगे।
अच्छा भैया ठीक है। एक उपाय है।
आप लोगों में से कोई मरना चाहता है तो
मैं इसको ज़िंदा कर सकता हूँ। बाकी 1 घंटे का ही मेहमान हूँ। 1 घंटे के बाद रहने वाला
हूँ। एक घंटे के बाद रहने
में भगवान। अब सोच लो आप हिसाब करो।
क्या वो रोने वालों के आँख में आँसू यहीं रुक गए नीचे नहीं उतरे।
अब कौन मरने को तैयार है? आँख से दिखता नहीं है, चल नहीं सकते,
ऐसे बूढ़े माँ-बाप को भी दया नहीं आई अपने बच्चों पे।
बच्चे के ऊपर। मरना कौन चाहेगा?
क्या? जिसके मुँह में हम फसते हैं वही नहीं चाहिए हमें। हम फँसते हैं वही
नहीं चाहिए हमारा। मुझे मेरा आत्मा चाहिए।
ऐसा अगर self के ऊपर आ जावे ना,
तो वो धर्म पा सकता है, बाकी नहीं पा
सकता। सबकी पंचायत करे, बच्चों का क्या, छोटे बच्चे हैं हम
सबका क्या। दुकान का क्या, दुकान कौन
संभालेगा? अभी तो कमाने दमाने की उम्र है।
जिंदगी भर कमाओगे ना तो भी वही बात रहेगी।
और चाहिए और चाहिए, कभी end नहीं है। कोई ना कोई
जीव ने अपने मोह में फँसा दिया है। कोई ना कोई कार्य में फँसा दिया है। में फंसा
दिया है कोई ना कोई कार्य में फंसा हुआ
है। अब वो दूसरा काम करने लगे तो फिर ये काम कौन करेगा? हमको तो
नसीब में झाड़ू लिखना रखा है ना झाड़ू मारना हर घर।
अनंत भाव की अनंत परिवार के साथ झाड़ू मारना। सब ठीक ठाक करना
सब बहन बना करके छोड़ के चले जाना एक दिन। वापस जा गए और नए
तरीके से शुरुआत करना। cycle की फेरी करते करते आज मैं करोड़पति बना हूँ
और AC में आज बैठने को मिला है
शांति से। यहीं मर जाओगे।
वापस जाओगे और कचरा कुंडी में। फिर वहां से वापस cycle की फेरी करते
करते वापस ऊपर आना। ये चक्कर है ये।
क्या है ये संसार? कभी ऊपर
कभी... कभी स्वर्ग में कभी... नरक में।
लेकिन ये हमारे जीवन पे रोज गुजरती है लेकिन हम नहीं सुधरे।
हम होंगे कामयाब एक दिन। लेकिन वो एक दिन कब आएगा? अपूर्व अवसर एवो... कियरे अवसर।
क्या रे आओ
सपने में देखते जाओ। बाकी ऐसा तो नहीं होने वाला। चाहे जितना उसका सुधार करे,
तो भी एकांतवास से जितना संसार क्षय होने वाला
है, उसका 100वाँ हिस्सा भी,
उस काजल ग्रह में रहने से नहीं होने वाला
है। अकेलेपन का अभ्यास महावीर के बोध का पात्र कौन? 7वाँ number का
point। सातवां number का point। एकांतवास की प्रशंसा
करने वाला, निवृत्ति को चाहने वाला।
कोई नहीं चाहिए, किसी का संगत नहीं चाहिए, मैं अकेला, अकेला, अकेला। ऐसी भावना तो
कम से कम हो अंदर में।
कार्य तो जब होने वाला होगा तब होगा। वो तो contract के ऊपर depend है।
अंदर में निवृत्ति की भावना है लेकिन हो सकता है हमारे contract ऐसे किए हैं।
के मरते दम तक निवृत्ति ना मिले, ऐसा भी हो सकता है।
पूर्व कर्मों की सजा तो काटनी पड़ती है। पूर्व कर्मों की सज़ा तो
काटनी पड़ती है लेकिन
जो भावना बाते हो वो फैल नहीं जाती। ये contract खत्म होते ही जैसी भावना
भाई ऐसे दिन आएंगे। निवृत्ति की भावना।
मुझे सिर्फ आत्मकल्याण करना है। ये निवृत्ति की भावना।
कुछ नहीं चाहिए कोई साथी संगathi नहीं चाहिए
किसी से help नहीं चाहिए। ये निवृत्ति की भावना।
Self dependent रहना है। ये निवृत्ति की भावना। अकेले। ये निवृत्ति
की भावना है अकेले रहना है
ऐसी भावना तो कम से कम भा सकती
है आत्मशांति वाला जीव तो भावना भाता है कोई नहीं चाहिए संसार का स्वरूप देखा है
अनुभव भी किया है
और कोई सार नहीं है संसार में real में कोई सार नहीं
है अपनी अपनी जिंदगी को
तपासो मालूम पड़ेगा। अपनी अपनी जिंदगी को तबाह
सो मालूम पड़ेगा। हम एक ही परिवार में बड़े
रहते हैं लेकिन कभी किसी से ना किसी को सुख दिया है।
ना सामने वाले ने अपने को सुख दिया है ना हमने किसी सामने वाले को सुख दिया
है। फिर वो नाटक रहता है birthday party ये सब काहे को मनाते हैं?
के रोज झगड़ा करते हैं एक दिन तो उसको wish करें।
लो हम भी कुछ चाहते हैं तुम्हारे पता नहीं सब wrong है।
फाड़ बिछाना ये सब क्या है? मिछा में तो
वो भी wrong है कोई। मिछा में जो करन वो भी ढोंग है कोई चाहता नहीं है एक दूसरे
पे लेकिन अभी एक दिन तो चाह कर रहा था।
कभी कभी इसीलिए मैं birthday wish करते हैं क्योंकि उसने हमारे को birthday wish किया
था अभी हमारे पे कर्जा हो गया है।
उसको चुकाने के लिए अभी हमको birthday wish करना है। सब नाटक नाटक नाटक की ही
दुनिया है पूरी।
संसार का
स्वरूप देखे तो ऐसा
है और आप। बार का स्वरूप देखे तो ऐसा है और राग
द्वेष निरंतर बढ़ते हैं। बार वाले तो कभी
अभी हमने तो सामने पैर भी नहीं रखा है।
सामने ही पड़ोसी हैं। ऊपर नीचे नहीं जा सकते लेकिन इधर कभी ना तक।
जाके भी नहीं देखते क्या करते हैं वो
कब आते हैं कब सो जाते हैं क्या करते हैं। लेकिन घर में
रोज 10 बजे आने वाला लड़का रात को 12 बजे तक नहीं आया तो क्या होता है बूढ़े माँ
बाप... तक नहीं आया तो क्या
होता है बूढ़े माँ बाप को। क्या हो
गया अभी तक क्यों नहीं आया? नींद नहीं आती है?
फौरन mobile चालू करते हैं अरे mobile भी बंद है switch off है।
अब देखो मज़ा आते ही दमादम। कितना लगाया phone अभी तक नहीं लगा।
मेरी battery down हो गई थी। पेपार दे रहा।
क्या वो सुन... अब क्या नहीं बोलता है क्या बोलता है?
मेरी battery down हो गई थी signal नहीं पकड़ रहा था। परेशान कितना होता है
जीव?
ये क्या है ये चीज़? अपनी आत्मा की फिक्र छोड़ कर के, बिना वजह
राग द्वेष बढ़ाने वाले दूसरों की फिक्र करना उसका नाम है
और परिवार का प्रेम। ये प्रेम नहीं है actual में राग है। हम उसको समझते हैं प्रेम।
प्रेम नहीं है, प्रेम होता ना तो
एक दूसरे को कभी दुखी नहीं करते। अपनी कुर्बानी दे देते। अपनी कुर्बानी दे रहे थे।
अगर परिवार वालों के सामने चाहते ना,
तो प्रेम में कभी मांगना नहीं होता है। कभी demand नहीं रहती। हमारा ये
आग्रह नहीं होता है कि ये हमारी बात माने ही माने।
प्रेम में कभी नहीं होता, प्रेम में surrendership रहता है। जिसमें
तू राजी है वो मुझे करना
है। इसका नाम प्रेम है। राग में क्या होता है? मैंने तेरे लिए इतना इतना किया है।
और तू मेरे को ऐसा उल्टा... तू मेरे को ऐसा उल्टा, ये द्वेष वहीं चालू है।
ये राग किया, इतने दिन तक साथ में रहकर के क्या किया?
प्रेम तो किया नहीं क्योंकि जिसे अपने
आत्मा से प्रेम नहीं है, वो दूसरों से क्या प्रेम करेगा?
लेकिन गिनती करेगा, प्रेम करने वाला गिनती नहीं करता है मैंने
दूसरों के लिए कितना किया।
अगर हम किसी से प्रेम करते हैं तो उसके लिए पूरी जान भी लुटा देते हैं।
अभी मांगेगा, हिसाब किताब नहीं मांगेगा।
कि देखो मैंने तुम्हारे लिए इतना इतना इतना इतना। मेहनत मार दी इतना
इतना इतना इतना कुर्बानियां दी।
ये इतना इतना किया। कभी हिसाब किताब नहीं होता। रात में हिसाब किताब होते हैं।
पूरी गिनती करके रखो।
कभी वक्त पे हिसाब बताना है भले लेना नहीं है लेकिन हिसाब तो बताना है लिख के रखना।
ताकि कभी वो मुंह खोलेगा ना तो उसको ये chapter बता देगा देख भाई क्या मुंह खोलते हो।
इसका हिसाब किताब कर। देख मां बेटे को प्रेम करती है।
अपना दूध पिलाती है कभी हिसाब किताब रखिए
कितना पिया कितना liter क्या हुआ कितना पैसा। वो हमेशा यही चाहती है कि
तू सुखी रहे तू सुखी
रहे। बीच में से हट जाती है।
अपने बेटे को जहाँ शांति होती है वो करने देती है। बीच में से अपने हट जाना।
कैसे कैसे सोई कैसे कैसे रही अपने साथ। बाजू में बिस्तर पे सोया है।
रात को भी पेशाब होता है तो मालूम पड़ते ही उसको सूखे पे अपने सूखे पे। वो वजह होती
है। पीके वजह। ये क्या है? ये प्रेम में कुर्बानियां होती हैं।
राग में कुर्बानी नहीं होती। राग में अपेक्षाएं बढ़ती हैं।
Condition बढ़ती हैं। हमने हमने क्या किया आज तक अपने
परिवार में रहकर? कभी किसी को प्रेम नहीं दिया। कभी किसी को प्रेम नहीं दिया
तो कभी प्रेम मिला भी नहीं हमको।
हम प्रेम करेंगे तो मिलेगा, प्रेम नहीं करेंगे तो कहाँ से मिलेगा?
हम राग द्वेष करें और सामने वाला हमारे से प्रेम करे कैसे बन सकता है?
हमको तो अपना एक भी छोड़ना नहीं है, पूरा हड़प लेना है।
और सामने वाले को बोलते हैं तू थोड़ा minus कर,
तू थोड़ा adjust कर। कैसे adjust करेगा?
कोई adjust नहीं करेगा। चाहे जितना
सुधा करे तो भी
एकांतवास... सुधा करे तो भी एकांतवास से जितना संसार क्षय होने वाला है। उसका
100वाँ हिस्सा भी उस काजक गृह में रहने से
नहीं होने वाला है। देखो। वो कसाय का निमित्त है। अपना घर है ना।
वो कसाय का निमित्त है
असल में वो घर भी नहीं है।
अपना घर थोड़ा है। अगर अपना घर होता तो छोड़ना क्यों होता?
अपना तो चैतन्य घर है। क्या वो अपना
कभी अलग... वो अपना कभी अलग नहीं होने वाला है अपना। वो permanent है। एक तो रेठी
मिट्टी, चूना, cement इसका है। और इस परिवार का है पूरा।
सब अपना-अपना मानते हैं।
इसके तो बहुत से वो
हैं क्या बोलते हैं भागीदार, partners। अपने घर का कोई partner नहीं
है, अपने घर के हम मालिक
हैं। असल में चैतन्य घर ही अपना घर है। जो ज्ञानमूर्ति है वो अपना घर है।
लेकिन इसको... देखिए इसको भूल करके हमने पराए घर में अपनापन किया। कितने घर बदले?
पहले माँ-बाप के घर में, फिर वहाँ से शादी हो करके अलग घर किया।
वो colony में गए, फिर वहाँ से खाली करके दूसरी colony में आए, फिर वहाँ से जाके तीसरा
चक्कर चलता है। और जहाँ गए ना वहाँ उतनी ममता से लगा करके,
कितनी ममता से सजाया, वापस छोड़ा वहाँ
से। ये भी घर है एक लेकिन पराया घर है ये जो इसको भी छोड़ना पड़ेगा। शरीर रूपी घर
उसके अंदर हमारा परमात्मा बसा हुआ है।
लेकिन कभी भी जिंदगी में आज तक अपने परमात्मा की सुध नहीं ली। घर की संभाल रखी
शरीर की, परिवार की, मकान की, building की।
Motor car को थोड़ा सा चुरका लगे तो ऊपर नीचे हो जाते हैं उसकी फिक्र रखी।
लेकिन अपने परमात्मा की जो असल में मूल है। जो
जिसको घर से लगाव है उसको ही भूल गए हम। इसीलिए वो कसाय का निमित्त है क्या है?
क्रोध मान माया लोभ ये कसाय है 4। वो
वो क्यों बढ़ते हैं खत्म क्यों नहीं होते हैं?
कि हम निरंतर ऐसे संग में रहते हैं।
कि नहीं चाहे तो भी
क्रोध मान माया। चाहें तो भी क्रोध,
मान, माया, लोभ आए बिना रहता? कितना भी control कर लें।
वो हुए बिना नहीं रहेंगे। और संग छोड़ना हमारे हाथ में नहीं
है। ये जो बाहर का जो संग मिला है शरीर से लेकर के, माँ-बाप से लेकर के, परिवार, और जो
बाहर की जो सुविधा-असुविधा जो भी है, संयोग है, वो
अपने हाथ में नहीं है। अब संग में रहे तो तकलीफ,
तो कसाए बढ़ते हैं। और नहीं रहना है तो... और नहीं रहना है तो ये
आपके हाथ की बात नहीं है।
कैसे फस गए हैं? देखो ये चक्कर में बैठे हैं।
चालू होने के बाद नीचे उतर सकते हैं। नहीं मेले में आता
है। इसको दर्द लगे अभी उतर जाओ।
क्या फिर बाद में वो रोएं धोएं कुछ भी नहीं होता भैया। पेट में दर्द होता
है, उल्टियां आती है भैया जो भी होगा होगा। मरने के लिए राजी हो
जाओ देखिए। मरने के लिए
राजी हो जाओ देखिए बाद में
कुछ नहीं। जाते हैं बहुत मज़ा करने के
लिए टोरा टोरा में बैठते हैं। और फिर देखो क्या
झटके लगते हैं। पूरी हवाइयां उड़ जाती हैं। क्या बोलते हैं वो
होता है ना ऐसा कुछ क्या क्या खेल खेल के। मैं भी गया था एक दिन। माने SL World में।
पर ऐसा में ऊपर क्या है और कुछ नहीं। नहीं वैसे ऊपर जाते हैं ऐसा में दम बोल
के नीचे उतरते हैं। नीचे उतरता
है। नहीं बोला नहीं
बोला। मैं बोला मैं अपने
को बचाने के लिए मैं बोला क्या करना है सांस रोक लो कुछ नहीं होगा।
और परेशानी होगी।
सांस रोकने की कोशिश की वो सुना था सांस रोकने से कुछ भी नहीं होता है
हाथी भी ऊपर चढ़ जाए तो कुछ नहीं होता है। बोले अपने को कुछ नहीं होगा सांस रोकते
ही second की बात है रोक लेंगे। लेकिन जो pressure आता है ना
सांस को पकड़ नहीं सकते बहुत कष्ट होता है। कुछ नहीं कर
सकते। 4 बार ऐसा ऊपर नीचे नहीं जाना नहीं उतरना था लेकिन क्या।
वापिस धन बल के ऊपर है, वापिस धन बल के नीचे गिर गए। फंस गए,
हम बीच में उतर नहीं सकते।
अब शर्म आती है, आता है अंदर से रोना
लेकिन शर्म आती है, रोएंगे तो कैसा सब लोग हंस रहे हैं,
अपुन भी हँसो रोते-रोते।
अंदर में रोना है, बाहर में हँसना है। चिल्लाना, वो करना, ये करना, उधर-उधर देखना।
सामने तो देख नहीं सकते तो
और चक्कर आ जाता। अभी अंदर ऐसा
ही देखने हैं। क्या?
हालत बन जाती है बराबर।
वैसे ही इसके अंदर ऐसा है।
कि चक्कर में बैठे ना, आप रोओ चाहे कुछ हँसो कुछ भी हो।
आप ना छोड़ सकते लड्डू है या फस गया।
ना नीचे निकाल सकते ना बाहर निकाल सकते, ऐसा फस गया कुछ। ये हाल हो जाते हैं।
ये कुटुंब रूपी काजल की कोठरी। साथ
में... साथ में नहीं रहे तो बोले कि तुम साथ में नहीं रहते हो कैसे हो?
अपने घर वालों के साथ में नहीं रहते हो
और साथ में रहे तो क्या होता है? रोज की पंचायतें।
एक दिन नहीं आता है झगड़े के बिना। एक दूसरे को
मुँह देखे तो जैसा राक्षस के जैसा देखते हैं।
हमेशा मुँह चढ़ा हुआ रहता है कभी शांति से प्रेम से रह ही नहीं सकते। ये सब क्या है ये
सब? सही में बोला है। ये कसाई का निमित्त है क्रोध मान माया
लोभ होने का ये निमित्त है। लोभ होने का ये
हिस्सा मिलता नहीं है और हिस्से
के लिए रहना है तो
constant जब तक हिस्सा नहीं मिलेगा ना तब तक मेरा हिस्सा मेरा हिस्सा मेरा हिस्सा।
ये क्या है ये लोभ कैसा है constant रहता
है। ये क्या मालूम मेरे को क्या सूझ आता था मैं तो बोला मेरे को कुछ नहीं चाहिए।
क्या तीन लुगड़े से निकलना चाहता हूँ। दागिना भी जो
आप शादी में दिए ना अगर वो भी चाहिए तो ये भी लो ये रखो।
हमको लेकिन हमको मेहरबानी करो। लेकिन हमको मेहरबानी करो, हमको
साथ में ले जाओ। क्या करोगे,
क्या खाओगे, क्या कौन सा धंधा करोगे? ऊपर आकाश है, नीचे धरती है, जो भी
होना होगा नसीब में होगा, हो
जाएगा। लेकिन आप हमारे को sign करो।
और 10 दिन लगे sign लेने में। हमको फिक्र होए, क्या करेगा लड़का?
ऐसे ही सब छोड़ कर के इसको अकल नहीं है, 2-2 बच्चे हैं, छोड़ के चले आता है, लेकिन
क्या होगा? हमको नहीं रहना, अशांति में हमको नहीं रहना, हमको शांति
चाहिए। सबको छोड़ सकते हैं।
लेकिन ये रोज़ के
क्रोध, मान, माया, लोभ हमारे से बर्दाश्त नहीं होते। ये अशांति, कसाय का निमित्त माने
कस, कस माने पीड़ा देना, किसको? अपने को। कस माने पीड़ा। आय माने
आते रहना, पीड़ा मिलते रहना, मिलते रहना। जैसे आँख में जब तक वो
कीटाणु नहीं निकालोगे तब तक क्या है? पीड़ा। ऐसे हृदय में जब
तक... ऐसे हृदय में जब तक क्रोध, मान, माया, लोभ निकले नहीं, कसाय निकले नहीं,
अंदर में बैठे नहीं, अशांति सब चालू है। अब क्या
कोई ना कोई लोभ के कारण वहीं रहना
चाहते हैं, वहीं फँसना चाहते हैं। भैया हमको चाहिए ही नहीं, मारो गोली सब।
भूखा प्यासा अंदर अकेले रह जाना अच्छा है, better है, लेकिन शांति से जीना
है। अशांति से हमको
जीना नहीं है। Life mini है। शांति के लिए mini है, अशांति के लिए नहीं
mini। शांति के लिए मिली है अशांति के लिए नहीं मिली। पैसा नहीं मिला तो नहीं मिला,
हिस्सा नहीं मिला तो नहीं मिला।
किसी का साथ नहीं मिला घर वालों का तो कोई बात
नहीं। कोई ऐसा मिल कहाँ
अपने हैं सिद्धांत की दृष्टि से तो कोई अपना है नहीं। अपना मानते हैं वो
अपनी गलती है। फिर कोई ना कोई लोभ के कारण कि हिस्सा मिले
तब तक राह देखना है क्या राह देखना है?
नसीब में होगा तो कोई लेके नहीं जाता है।
और नहीं होगा तो साथ में रहो
जिंदगी भर तकलीफ उठाओ तो। रहोगे जिंदगी भर तकलीफ उठाओ तो भी आपको
नहीं मिलने वाला है, नहीं मिलने वाला। छोड़िए तो, मगज मरी थी, चाहिए ही नहीं।
इसके लिए बहुत आत्मबल और आत्मशांति का लक्ष्य चाहिए, तो छोड़ सकते हो।
बाकी परिवार तो...
परिवार में रहना बोलो तो कसाई का निमित्त है। कसाई कराने वाले नहीं हैं।
परिवार वाले कसाई के निमित्त हैं। कसाई आप करते हो, अपने अज्ञानता के कारण।
आपके मोह के कारण। आप मोह छोड़ो। आपके मोह के कारण आप मोह
छोड़ो। आप अपना मोह छोड़ो, कोई कुछ नहीं करता है।
कि क्रोधमान माया लोक में निमित्त नहीं हो।
लेकिन वो निमित्त कब बनते हैं? जब आप गलती करते हो, तब वो निमित्त बनते हैं।
आप अपने स्वरूप को भूल जाते हो। अपने आत्मशांति के target को भूल जाते हो।
आत्मा के पीछे नहीं लगते हो, फिर वो क्या होता है?
फिर वो निमित्त बन जाते हैं। अगर
आप alert हो, आप जागृति में हो, आपको... आप
alert हो, आप जागृति में हो, आपको अपने आत्मा पे प्रेम है।
अपने आत्मा की दया आती है।
तो परिवार वाले कुछ नहीं कर सकते, आपकी शांति को
थोड़ा भी भंग नहीं कर सकते। लेकिन आप ही नहीं रह सकते हो ना ठिकाने
पे। तो कषाय का उपादान नहीं है, ये कषाय
का... उपादान कौन है कषाय का? अपना मोह, अपने को भूल करके,
अपने आत्मा की चिंता नहीं करके,
दूसरों की चिंता करना, ऐसा जो अपना मोह है, जो अज्ञान है, ये... जो
अपना मोह है जो अज्ञान है ये कषाय का उपादान है।
जब हम ऐसी गलती करते हैं तो बाद में कोई ना कोई very nearest कौन है सबसे पहले शरीर
और next में कौन है? परिवार वाले। वो क्रोध मान माया लोभ में निमित्त बनते हैं।
मोह के रहने का अनादिकालीन पर्वत है। देखो।
अपने को जीव भूलता है।
अपने को भूल करके कहाँ रहता है वो? सारा दिन। सारा दिन करता क्या
है? अपना मन शरीर को अपना मानता है तो पहले उसकी सेवा करता
है जितना चाहे उतना। यहाँ से अगर हटा तो अंदर तो आता नहीं
है। अंदर तो देखा नहीं है और बाहर जाता है तो nearest कौन है?
शरीर के बाद nearest कौन है? शरीर के उत्पन्न करने वाले माँ-बाप,
पत्नी, पुत्र ये सब हैं।
सबसे ज़्यादा विकल्प उनके ही आते हैं। Business करने
आता है। Business करने जाता है अकेला काहे के वास्ते जाता
है? अपने अकेले के लिए जाता है। कितना चाहिए चाचा को?
अपने परिवार को सुखी करने के लिए। कि लड़के को पढ़ाना है।
तो पैसा कमाना है, उसको college की fee भरनी है।
या घर में TV नहीं है, TV की demand है। Vehicle चाहिए तो vehicle चाहिए, तो उसका।
ये सब काहे के वास्ते है सब?
पूरा परिवार है ये सब। पूरे परिवार का बोझ है और फिर ये... पूरे परिवार का बोझ है और
फिर ये चक्कर ये मोह रूपी बैल।
समय सार में भी आया है starting में चौथी नंबर की बात
में। ये मोह रूपी भूत है ना। ये जीव राजा को ऐसा बांध के रख दिया है।
काम कराओ राग द्वेष कराओ काम कराओ। रात दिन और कभी file बंद नहीं होगा।
एक एक file खुलते जावे रोज के रोज। आज तो account बंद हो
जाएगा लेकिन 15 दिन और चल गया है। पुराना करने जाओ तब तक। पुराना करने जाओ तब
तक 15 दिन का और नया
आया है। क्या कैसा बंद होता है वो?
बंद होने का नहीं है। चक्की चलती रहती है।
करो करो करो करो और एक दिन आओ चले जाओ तुम।
अभी पूरे नहीं होने वाले। ये मोह रूपी भूत उसको
अंदर में घुस गया है। अब पूरा काम कराता है मजो जी। नाचो।
कूदो राग द्वेष करो क्रोध मान माया लोभ जी भर के करो।
और नए नए कर्म बांध। ओ नये नये कर्म बांध बांध करके जाओ गलेक नीकळो.
एक गुरुदेव की language में तो हर प्रवचन में ए बाधा देते बाईडी छोकरा धंधो जापो.
आने कई अक्कल ज नथी. शुं? धूळनी पाछळ पड्यो छे शुं धूळ धूळ धूळ एटले शुं पैसा.
गुरुदेव के हर lecture में मिलेगा ए
बांध. बडा मजूर है बडा मजूर. थोडा मांगे
छोटा भिखारी और बडा राजा जेसा है वो ज्यादा मांगे वो
बडा भिखारी है. भावनगर के राजा. बड़ा भिखारी। बावनगर के राजा
आए सुनने के लिए। उनका नाम लेकर के बोले। क्या? राजा
की property की बात होती है इधर किराए पे दिया, उधर किराए पे दिया, इतनी
सारी property है। राजा है। सब जगह से किराया आता है हर महीने।
और लाखों-अब्जों रुपये की पैदास होती है हर महीने की। बैठ के
मज़ा में खाना, घूमना, बाहर-बाहर।
बोले थोड़ा मांगे वो थोड़ा भिखारी
और ज़्यादा मांगे वो... ज़्यादा भिखारी, उनको भिखारी कह दिया।
बड़ा भिखारी। ना भिखारी उनको भिखारी कह दिया, बड़ा
भिखारी कहा वो। मजूर मजूर। गुरुदेव उनको शर्म नहीं
होती। और गांधी जी को ही बोल दिया बड़े मजूर हो तुम।
क्या? सारा देश,
लोग क्या है सामान उठाते हैं,
बिस्तरा पुतला उठा रहे हैं, लाओ विदेश रुपया। और तुम क्या करते हो?
तुम सारे देश की उपाधि लेते हो सर। गांधी जी को बोल दिया,
बड़े मजूर हो, तुम्हारे जैसा मजूर नहीं मिलेगा दुनिया में। करनी है। मुँह पे बोलने का।
डरने मरने वाला नहीं है क्योंकि देश सेवा करते हो पुण्य इकट्ठे करोगे।
अभी नहीं लेते हो बाद में मिलेगा यार। स्वर्ग में सब मिलने वाला
है। इतनी सेवा करते हो नहीं मिलेगा? कहाँ भोगोगे?
अभी तो बोले कि नहीं मुझे कुछ नहीं चाहिए निस्वार्थ सेवा करना है लेकिन भैया
ऐसा नहीं चलता है। निस्वार्थ सेवा करोगे तो ज्यादा मिलता है।
कुछ मांग करके लेते हो तो नहीं मिलता है ज्यादा। तो यहीं कुछ थोड़ा बहुत नाम
साम मिल जाता है। तो यहीं
कुछ थोड़ा बहुत नाम साम मिल जाता है, फूल
की माला मिल जाती है, कुर्सी मिल जाती है, तो 50% यहीं cutting
हो जाता है। बीमे के दो प्रकार होते हैं, मालूम है? क्या? बीमे, बीमे
करने का, life insurance। एक तो आप भरते
जाओ, फिर 5 साल के बाद आपको थोड़ा-थोड़ा मिलते जाएगा
हर 5 साल में। तो आखिरी में कम मिलता है। क्या?
और एक तो नहीं, आप जमा ही करते जाओ, भरते वक्त या
end होगा तब बहुत ज्यादा amount आएगा।
क्योंकि आपने बीच में कुछ लिया नहीं है ना। ऐसे ही सेवा करते जाओ
कुछ फूल की मालाएं पहनते
जाओ तो क्या होगा? आखिरी में कम मिलता है।
गांधी जी को कम नहीं मिला।
गांधी जी को बहुत मिला है क्यों? क्योंकि कभी मांगा नहीं और सेवा करते गए।
कहाँ गए स्वर्ग में?
वहाँ बहुत पैर दबाने वाले हाथ दबाने वाले बहुत हैं। और भाग भी नहीं सकते
आज नहीं चाहिए तो कहाँ से भागोगे भैया स्वर्ग से कैसे
भागोगे? Before maturity आप भाग नहीं सकते लेना ही पड़ता है।
आखिर यहाँ नहीं मिला तो वहाँ मिला। मिलेगा तो सही। छोड़ के कैसे भागूँ?
इसीलिए अपने करने का फल तो अपने को मिलता ही
है। कुछ भी नहीं करें जीव जानने देखने में रहे तो मुक्ति है।
बाकी बुरा करें तो तो भी है।
जूते रेडी हैं तैयार हो रहे हैं
सब। और अच्छा करें
अभी कुछ मत मांगो। बाद में ज्यादा ले लेना। मांगो। बाद में ज़्यादा ले
लूँगा ब्याज के साथ जमा हो जाएगा। हाँ मिलेंगे।
हमने निस्वार्थ भाव से सेवा की है लेकिन भैया तुमने
सेवा की है ना अपनी तो नहीं के लिए कुछ।
मुक्ति तो नहीं मिलेगी। जाओ उधर ऊपर। भोगने के लिए।
इसलिए मोह के रहने का अनादिकालीन पर्वत है। नहीं चाहिए नहीं चाहिए तो भी।
फिर वहाँ जहाँ मिलेगा ना वहाँ मोह करना ही पड़ेगा।
जहाँ जाओगे वहाँ अभी नहीं करते हो वहाँ मोह करोगे। वा के वा अभी नहीं
करते वा मोह करो। ये मोह छूटता नहीं है अंदर से। एक कुटुंब परिवार में रहना
ये कसाय का निमित्त है मोह रखना। और मोह में मोह के रहने का अनादि कालीन पर्व है।
एक तो हम अपने स्वरूप को भूले हुए हैं।
और फिर उस गलती को और मजबूत करने के लिए और मजबूत करने के लिए।
उस उस मोह रूपी पौधे को पानी पिलाने के लिए।
ये सब है। रोज पानी डालते जाओ तो छूटता
ही नहीं। रोज पानी डालते जाओ तो सूखता ही नहीं कभी मोह।
रोज पानी पिलाओ।
ये मोह का झाड़ कभी सूखता नहीं। ये प्रत्येक अंतर गुफा में जाज्वल्यमान है।
हर एक अज्ञानी जीव के अंदर में तो पड़े हैं चोर। क्रोध, मान, माया, लोभ,
शरीर का प्रेम, परिवार का प्रेम, अंदर चोर पड़ा है।
प्रत्येक अंतर गुफा में जाज्वल्यमान है, ये तो नहीं मिलता है, हमारे नसीब में नहीं
है। अगर नसीब होता तो एक को
किसी और को देते। अगर नसीब होता तो एक को किसी और को देते नहीं कुछ। शास्त्र में आया
है एक बात। कि इस जीव को इतनी तृष्णा है,
कितना देखना है कि बे limit, limit नहीं है। कितना सुनना है कि कोई limit नहीं है।
कितना खाना है कि कोई limit नहीं है, इच्छा रही, इच्छा का हेन नहीं है।
लेकिन क्या करें नसीब में जितना है उतना मिलता है।
अगर पूरे अगर खुल जावे ना बाप, तो ये दुनिया की जितनी संपत्ति है या जो कुछ भी है,
ये किसी और को देगा नहीं अगर ताकत होती।
पूरा अकेला ही हड़प लेगा। रेखा होती है। पूरा अकेला ही हड़प लेता है। इतनी अंदर में है
तो भी भूखा का भूखा रहेगा। तो भी इच्छाओं का अंत होने वाला
नहीं है। इच्छा रूपी समुद्र का अंत नहीं है।
उसका कोई किनारा नहीं है, उसका कोई end नहीं है।
ये धरती और आकाश मिलते हैं, कभी end होगा?
लगते हैं कि मिले हुए हैं लेकिन मिले हुए हैं
और आगे जाओ क्या होता है? और आगे चले जाओ, क्षितिज
रेखा बोलते हैं इसको। चले हैं क्षितिज रेखा बोलते हैं
वो मिले हुए लगते हैं लेकिन धरती और आकाश कभी मिलते नहीं हैं
इसका end नहीं है endless है इसी प्रकार इच्छाओं का अंत नहीं है आशा रूपी खड्डा
बाहर से कुछ लेने की जो इच्छा है कभी पूरा होने वाला नहीं है
सुधार करते हुए अगर आपको उसको इच्छाओं को नाश करना है
सुधार करना है तो कदाचित। तो कदाचित संभव।
कदाचित माने क्या? 100% sure नहीं बोल सकते लेकिन शायद, कदाचित।
श्राद्ध उत्पत्ति होना संभव है। माने क्या?
श्राद्धोत्पत्ति माने क्या? श्रावक धर्म। नीचे अर्थ दिया है।
श्राद्ध माने श्रावक धर्म। उत्पत्ति माने प्रगटता। ये श्राद्ध वगैरह करते हैं,
पूजा पाठ करते हैं, अच्छा काम करते हैं। ये ये सज्जन... ये ये
सज्जनों के श्रावकों के धर्म हैं। यहाँ श्राद्धोत्पति माने क्या सुधार शायद हो
सकता है प्रभु भक्ति में लग सकते हो
पूजा पाठ में लग सकते हो अपना कल्याण कर सकते हो। लेकिन वो chances हैं
अगर सुधार करना चाहो तो। लेकिन उसके लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा?
अगर अपने को मोह में नहीं फँसना है परिवार में रहते हुए भी।
शरीर में रहते हुए भी अपने को मोह में नहीं फँसना है।
जो गलतियाँ करते हैं, क्रोध, मान, माया, लोभ बढ़ाते हैं, अगर वो नहीं करना है,
सुधर जाना है,
तो हम सुधर सकते हैं। लेकिन इसके लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा? आप कोशिश करके देखो,
शायद आपका कल्याण हो जाए।
Guarantee नहीं है, क्यों guarantee नहीं है? कि ये जो बताए रास्ते हैं,
वो चरणानियोग के हैं, द्रव्यानियोग के नहीं
हैं। क्या? असल में जो मूल फायदा होता है... असल में जो
मूल फायदा होता है वो अवलोकन से और वेद ज्ञान से होता है।
और यहाँ पर जो कृपादेव ने जो बातें बताई हैं,
उन्होंने अवलोकन की बात नहीं बताई,
वेद ज्ञान की बात नहीं बताई। जो इलाज बताया है,
क्रोध, मान, माया, लोभ को कम करने का इलाज बताया है, वो इलाज
चरणान योग के हिसाब से बताया है।
क्योंकि अभी आत्मा तो मिला नहीं था, तो द्रव्याण योग की बात कैसे
करेंगे? अवलोकन भी 108 से शुरू होता है, 1... अवलोकन
भी 108 से शुरू होता है, 103 number है ये। उनको वैराग्य था परिवार से,
क्यों? कि जातिस्मरण ज्ञान में बहुत
से परिवारों को छोड़ा था, 900 भवों
का पूरा ज्ञान था। 900 भव जन्मे और मरे,
सुधी, अलग-अलग वेश धारण किया, सब उनको पता था। तो वैराग्य बहुत था।
और जिस कारण से शरीर मिलते गए,
change होते गया, वो क्रोध, मान, माया लोग, वो भी पता चल गया। उनको छोड़ना भी है।
लेकिन अंदर की line मिली नहीं थी अभी। इसीलिए अंदर की बात का उपाय नहीं बताए।
यहाँ जो उपाय बताते हैं कृपावदेव, वो चरणवान योग की दृष्टि से बताए।
कौन से उपाय बताते हैं?
इसीलिए यहाँ, मतलब कुटुंब में रहते हुए
आपको क्या करना है? 7 मुद्दे
हैं। 7 मुद्दे का विचार करना है। सबसे पहले अल्पभाषी होना।
ये ज़बान पे control पहले सबसे पहले कर लेना। ये ज़बान बहुत गड़बड़ करती है।
तलवार नहीं काटती है लेकिन ज़बान का घाव तो
ऐसा गहरा जाता है। कि जीव मरते दम तक नहीं भूलता। उसने मुझे ऐसा कहा था।
खलास। बहुत कम
बोलना। ज़बान पे
control करना। अब ये control
कर सकते हैं कि नहीं कर सकते दूसरी बात। नहीं कर सकते दूसरी बात है लेकिन control
जिन्होंने control किया है उसको बहुत फायदा हुआ है
जो कर सके हैं इसलिए कदाचित लिखा है ना सुधार करते हुए कदाचित साधोत्पत्ति
होना संभव है कदाचित doubt है
क्योंकि भूतकाल में भी उन्होंने ऐसा कुछ कोशिश किया होगा लेकिन संभव नहीं हुआ होगा
लेकिन फिर भी the best बताते हैं best उपाय बताते हैं कि हम गलती करते हैं मुँह से
नहीं। कि हम गलती करते हैं, मुँह से
नहीं चाहते, अभी कुछ निकल जाता है ना, फिर गड़बड़ बढ़ जाती है। इसलिए क्या करना?
मौन रहना नहीं है।
मौन रहना अलग बात हो गई, इन्होंने क्या शब्द लिखा है?
अल्पभाषी होना। मौन रहना तो व्यवहार कैसे करोगे?
गलत तो अपने को है तो बोलना तो पड़ेगा। कि खाना दो,
इतना तो बोलना पड़ेगा। कम बोलना। हाँ, कम बोलना। मौन रहना अलग।
मौन रहना अलग हो गया। मौन रहना तो अंदर चलते रहता है। मौन तो reversible है। मौन तो
impossible है। मुंदाना का साची। मौन तो
impossible है। फिर अपने को गरज है तो
क्या बोलना?
सामने वाला
क्या करता है
अपने को बराबर तपाता है। समझता ही नहीं है आखिर बोलना पड़ता है।
वो अपने को बुलाने के लिए समझता है फिर भी नहीं बोलता है कुछ भी नहीं करता
है। बोलेगा आज उसको बुला के रखना है।
क्या आग्रह हो जाता है। इससे better है कि आप दाल में नमक जितना
बोलो ना। दाल में नमक जितना बोलो ना, जरूरत पड़े उतना अपना काम निकलवा लो।
दूसरा ज्यादा रंजत नहीं करना, ज्यादा पंचायत discussion उसमें, guidance
में... विचार खत्म करो।
discussion खत्म करो। विचार नहीं मिलते हैं,
discussion खत्म करो। और मेरे को topic पे
बात नहीं करना, मेरे को दूसरा काम है। मालूम पड़ गया
कि इसका इरादा क्या है,
हमारा इरादा क्या है, matching नहीं हो
रहा है, दोनों को विचार नहीं जुड़ना। No argument. तू तेरे हिसाब से... argument तू
तेरे हिसाब से मैं मेरे हिसाब से
argument नहीं बातचीत ही बात। उस विषय में बातचीत बाकी दूसरा विषय भी चालू रखो क्योंकि
उसको भी गरज है और अपने को भी। महात्मा नहीं बन गए तो गरज तो अपने को भी
है। इसलिए मौन नहीं होना है
अल्पभासी होना है। ये first number है। दूसरा है अल्पहासी
अपना time होता है कल ही देंगे।
ये 7 मुद्दे हैं कल देंगे।
बहुत important है। असल में आखिरी में उन्होंने लिया
है अवलोकन भी। में आखिरी में उन्होंने लिया है अवलोकन भी
लिया है लेकिन अलग ढंग से लिया है।
क्योंकि
वो अवलोकन 108 में चालू होने वाला है तो उसकी तैयारी अभी से ही होती
है। बात तो एक ले लिया है।
लेकिन ये मुद्दे German योग के हैं।
जो अवलोकन कर सकता है उसके लिए बहुत easy है
लेकिन जो अवलोकन नहीं कर सकता है उसके लिए easy
नहीं है। लेकिन उसका चर्चा कल करेंगे। 7 point।